hi today
I will explain the European union
and its operation
the European Union is a union
political and economic
composed of 27 states
I put you a card
of all the countries that are present
the first countries are western germany italy
france the Netherlands
belgium and luxembourg
the continent should not be confused
with the European Union
there is also the schengen space
free movement space
which means that there is no need for a passport
there is also the euro zone
all the countries have adopted the currency
how the eu works
there are four important places
the european council in brussels
the 27 Heads of State and Government
sit to impulse
orientations for the European Union
the European Commission is also
in brussels the chief and ursula von der leyen
there are 27 commissioners who propose laws
the eu council is also located in brussels
there are 27 ministers who sit there
and there is the European Parliament
in strasbourg
where the seven hundred and five MEPs are elected
these two bodies
vote on European budgets and laws
there is also the European Central Bank
located in francfort
this organization is supranational
that is,
these laws are more important
than those of the member states